what's going on in the world oh we just
celebrated uh
25 years of rayquan's only built for
cuban links
that's wild man i can't believe he's
been 25
so that is uh
you know one of the greatest hip-hop
albums ever
i i would say it's in the top 20
easy to 25 of all time
i don't have it in my top 10 per se but
a lot of people do and i
i'm not mad at him i mean
it's become so like the purple tape is
synonymous
with greatness at this point 100
[Music]
um
so i thought it would be dope since
obviously
it's not a wu-tang album it's but you
know it's a it's a it's a lutang album
i thought it'd be dope if we tried to
rank our top 10
favorite wu tang albums now it's
important
that we distinguish the categories of
what qualifies as a wu-tang album
i just did woof solo and wu albums
okay so is kappa donna considered are we
including kappa donna in the in
in wu-tang he's not in your top ten
so that's that's irrelevant the pillage
might might sneak in
it's not in your top ten okay
okay so we're not including kappa donna
no kappa donna
and we're not including sons of man
killer army killer priest
etc nope none of that so just the nine
main members and then group albums
and those ranked correct correct
and we're gonna go 10.
you want my 10 first
yeah give me your 10. ten all right let
me go ten to one
no no we going ten to ten ten to ten
what do you what are you talking about
my ten year ten no i mean you go from t
you're ten
you're to one that's what i'm saying we
gotta build this up dog
all right go all right
i'm gonna go with this is this is my
only battle that i've had
thinking about this but i gotta say
i'm sorry to mr hot nickels to cal
you're off the list we're going to w
the w i'm going to w yeah man
i was listening back the past couple
days when we were talking about this and
the w i just love so many songs out here
like i can't go to sleep one of my
favorite joints
protect your neck gravel pit hollow
bones
so you put so you're so you're saying to
cow man the man's the cow's not on your
list at all not on my list
interesting it was rough man but
just going track for track like listen
to cal
again it just it didn't hit me like it
used to
hmm that's what sucks about about method
man i feel like method man's
solo oh how about this for a question
is method man a red man included or no
nope
that's not included blackout would have
been on my list but blackout one and two
is not included
not included okay all right well that's
fair
so you're you're saying uh the w as ten
the w which by the way was uh
i guess probably a slept on album at
this point super slept on
there was a lot of hate when the album
came out yeah for sure
all right what about nine oh what's your
ten
no man we're going 10 to 10 yeah
oh yeah
a little head-to-head
for me
i'm gonna put i'll give to cow number
ten
actually yeah to cal
method man to cal number 10. just
sneaking in huh
yeah unfortunately i think method man's
solo
career has been extremely disappointing
uh to cows clearly his best solo album
2000 was all right i liked 2000 actually
if i'm being honest i liked a few
records on there a lot
but yeah points i think you gotta go uh
you gotta have to cow in your top ten
that's what i thought but
couldn't do it man all right what's your
uh what's your number nine
number nine another woo album
iron flag super slept on back-to-back
woo
albums it's just like oozy
the y'all been warned chrome wheels like
they they just sounded hungry on the
album because
the w was so hated on at the time
all right you know what i'm iron flag
didn't make my top 10.
so like i said slept on
iron flag and i like to think of it as
their last album
definitely because everything else after
that i'm good
just it just hits a wall
number nine for me is um
odb returned to 36 chambers
i think old dirty bastard uh not a
perfect album not like a
you know there's better albums but i
think that odb
was important to hip hop and i feel like
this was his uh
i mean there's there are songs on here
that you'll hear in movies for the rest
of your life
but this was another album like takao
for me when
it's not on my list i went back and
listened to return to 36 chambers
isn't on your list either didn't make it
so no to cow
and no return to 36 chambers on your
list i went back and listened to it
there's there's joints on there but
there's just a lot of childish stuff
man like odb was on i don't know it just
it didn't age well to me that's fair i
can i can um i can
unders you know what to be fair i didn't
go back and listen for this
discussion so um
all right go ahead here's what's your
number eight
it's only built for cuban leagues two
ooh
yes amazing super fire you need
if you haven't listened to it in a while
you got to go back like it's just
the production on this is so crazy you
got
alchemists dilla pete rock just
on and on scram jones hey guess what
i have the same album at number eight
there you go
i love when they go for cuban links i
forgot he had the uh
they did mad lib the red they had that
beat on there
yeah that's right super fire me or no
i'm tripping i was about to say
ten bricks yeah um that was on fish
scale anyway
um all right what's your number seven
number seven
is fish scale dude
same word okay
yeah no again the production on this
joint was was nuts
uh it just this was
probably the uh
for this are only built too dude
what was first uh
i think fishtail was first there was
like a little renaissance right here
with this
fish scale was first fish scale was 06.
and um
only bill two was oh nine okay
but yeah fifth skill had a with me with
a strap and the production on it was
[ __ ] crazy
crazy the uh just vladimir that's
actually the last ghost face album that
i loved even though i know he's put out
a lot of other stuff that
is probably super dope but i just apolo
kids is fire
apollo kids was it was dope yeah all
right so ghostface
we both have at number seven what's your
number
six wu tang forever
damn that's low all right wu tang
forever number six
yes sir i mean it's just i love this
album but it's
the double disc dilemma as always like
it's so hard to
to nail it down if you got that many
tracks you know
like blueprint two it's that same
syndrome like it could have been
a lot higher right just condensed
a lot of filler but strong tracks on
there
and the production going back and
listening it was just so it was a lot
different than
enter the 36 chambers like number six
for me is iron man
ghostface his first solo album
shout out to rayquan another one of
their combo
i mean i kind of love just listening to
only built for cuban links and iron man
i just kind of feel like they complement
each other iron man
number i just remember having that like
silver cd it was like
like with the wu tang w and the iron man
chest
um and this is the album that really
like
solidified as uh ghost face being my
favorite member of wu tang
absolutely yeah that's my number five
shout out to ghost face
so you're going five now and you have
iron man
i got iron man at five yeah it's just
it's got so many of my favorite tracks
all that i got is you is still like
tongues like woo tanks ever put out
so my number five
is
my number five is uh
a supreme clientele
so back-to-back ghost face albums
supreme clientele holy [ __ ]
crazy album shout out to ghostface who
just
i mean man i remember buying this cd
from like sam goody at metro center mall
in phoenix when i was a kid
yes sir i copped out the warehouse and
this was like uh
the first time ghostface had like a solo
quote-unquote hit
that you like heard on the radio
yeah it got mad play on mtv the [ __ ] was
all over mtv
i still don't know how to say it though
but
chairs with ghosts
whatever it is um
and this was i think
ghostface carrying wu-tang on his back
because if you think about when this
came out this was like 99 right
2 000. okay but think about it like
wu tang forever came out in 97. this is
three years after that
you really can't this was the era where
method man started to become more of a
a star as for other [ __ ] besides his
music
um and it was like a really dry era of
like wu-tang
quality jizzer was putting out [ __ ] that
wasn't hidden
like everyone had hoped the wu-tang
album
was the we we talked about the w this
dropped before the w
this was like this was like summer i
think
okay yeah but they came out the same
year yeah
um i mean if you look at that whole
entire like
like 99 inspected deck drop uncontrolled
substance which i do think is a is an
underrated album but
100 not in that same discussion so
um i just think wu tang had a very as
far as like carrying like the brand
of what wu tang means and like meant to
fans
i feel like odb had already kind of gone
pop and stopped
banging wu tang like you know like um
you know he had to get got your money
[ __ ] with with kalis
i feel like the [ __ ] is singing this
album like kept bhutan alive
to like wu tang fans you feel me like
this [ __ ] was like
this felt like a wu-tang album this [ __ ]
was like raw
yeah shout out to supreme clientele it
honestly could have been higher
but it's uh number five on my list
what's your number four
supreme clientele fair enough
my number four is wu tang forever
we got that hi okay of course
i think wu tank forever is one of the
most slept on albums ever bro
yeah it's a double disc of just fire you
think it's straight
i think the beginning of disc one it's
fire you know what it is
is people people were expecting 36
chambers
yeah and that's the reason why people
listen
to that album or listen to that album
three years after that was when
dude wu-tang was doing i remember seeing
them they were torn with like [ __ ]
rage against the machine
and that this was like superstar wu-tang
era when they dropped wu-tang forever
they were like the biggest [ __ ] in the
world
um all right just set it off
bro triumph is on this album
probably one of the best hip-hop singles
of all time
probably a top five verse ever from
inspected deck
is on this album ever i'm talking about
ever like ever
not like wu-tang ever i mean just ever
and everybody knows it wu tank fan or
not you
know that expected deck first and for
the record
to a double disc of just fire peak
wu-tang
it's two album it's two albums in one
and we're talking peak wu-tang peak
ghost face peak rayquan peak method man
rizza it's different than 36 chambers so
i think when people initially heard it
they weren't necessarily on board with
it it was a little bit more commercial
i wouldn't say commercial yeah like a
song like it's yours was like
a hook you know it was just it was
different but i feel like
it was just a more like cleaned up not
like
it wasn't as rough as it sounded like it
was recorded in like
million dollar studios you know what i'm
saying like yeah it wasn't in the
basement
but i think we'll take forever is
[ __ ] incredible and
i think that actually aged well unlike
uh it did
so shout out to wu-tang i got that at
number four where are you at where's
where's your number three
i think i'm gonna shock you with this
one you're uh you're gonna put enter the
wu tang here huh
only built for cuban links oh
and i think we agree really
okay now this album is incredible
number three i wanted to put it the top
three it bounced around for me
all over the place but as far as out
there too
okay now for me
our personal opinions yeah so now we
know the final two
i got i got only built for cuban links
at three by the way it could be two or
it could be one
i do feel like the top three here could
at any given time be interchangeable
absolutely i'm just going to bust down
the rest of my uh my list you do the
same so i
i got liquid swords at 2 and 36 chambers
at 1.
i got the same like it's just i almost
put liquid swords at one low key but i
was like not 36 chambers is a perfect
album
it's perfect i had it at one you had the
swords
yeah i changed it because for me liquid
swords
album wise like just the flow of it
there's almost nothing like any hip-hop
like
it's just a move i i hate i also hate
the fact that liquid swords isn't as
celebrated as purple tape
it's just because rey and ghosts are
is the most low-key [ __ ] ever
by the way it kind of sucks that jizza
dropped liquid swords
and then besides his album he did with
mugs which was what called mastermind
masterminds
i just feel like beneath the surface
grand master sorry
beneath the surface was was submitted
like
it just kind of sucks that jizzle like
never
gave us something close to liquid swords
and for the record
rayquan the same could be said for him
up until he dropped liquid swords too
because
outside of uh only bill for cuban links
rayquan's solo career up until he
dropped
uh only bill for cuban links too was
there was a lot to be desired there
yeah mobility wasn't great and the other
one lex diamond story not great
so we got raquan at three
only built for cuban links is three
liquid swords is two
and number one is 36 chambers 36
chambers to me
i have as a top six seven eight
hip-hop album of all time and that's why
it was hard for me to not have it at
number one
because like in the grand scheme of
things it started routine come on and
it's a perfect it's literally a perfect
album like there's not one song on there
that you're like dang they could they
could have did without this one but
you can't skip anything on there yeah
it's a classic
um and for the record all top three of
those albums are classics
and had we have included the blackout it
would have been in the top ten
what do we have different um
i don't have the w in mine and to kell
and the w
was the only difference no uh you also
had iron flag in your top ten i didn't
have that in my top ten
i had odb oh that's right that's right
so so you had all four wu-tang albums in
your top ten i did not sir
eight diagrams we just will pretend like
that never happened it never happened
and the joint that uh what's that cat
that bought the album that's
can't release for a hundred years oh you
uh
martin shkreli or whatever the [ __ ] oh
that's right yeah that guy
[ __ ] that dude piece of [ __ ]
yeah so shout out to wu tang man 25
years since uh the purple tape came out
and i do feel like
i mean man i just wish we'd hear more
rayquan
i feel like it was dope to him at the
beginning of the griselda album but he
wasn't rapping he was just talking his
talk
and unfortunately you know
like when he hopped on like [ __ ] my
beautiful dark twisted fantasy
ten years ago it was like oh my god this
is great yeah
but shout out to ray you know another
slept on rayquan album
is uh shaolin versus wu tang that came
out in
after only built for cuban links that is
a dope joint
what about some um i'll say this
my uh
got a shout out a couple of albums that
i do think are underrated from wu-tang
members
for me i got a shout out uncontrolled
substance
inspector dex album was was was was fire
super fire and it it would have been
bigger but
the whole situation i guess the masters
got lost and he had to re-record it so
what could have been right there too
like i think he was supposed to be the
first
wu-tang um he was supposed to be after
meth i think
yeah i think i think uh unfortunately
yeah
he had to wait that sucks because that's
another what if career right if expected
deck would have dropped like
right off the rip yeah with the big wave
when everybody dropped through
think about inspect the deck stand out
versus like that full low key be out
wrapping everybody
always kills me once above the clouds
i was gonna say above the clouds from
gangstar jesus christ to cal come on man
um
another one i enjoyed was to cal 2000
that's like a personal
one that there's just some [ __ ] on there
i actually really like even though it's
it's a disappointing album um
master killers album no said date was
solid
what about bobby digital bobby digital
was solid
honestly just from like uh
sonically i just i almost was like
[ __ ] mike mom i [ __ ] around to sneak
bobby digital in number 10.
even though it don't deserve to be
number 10 but like
show love to rizza um
grave diggers yeah i see we didn't
include the grave diggers that would
have been in there
a hundred percent yeah um none of the
you got albums ever
spoke to me um i only listened to the
first one the woo massacre album is
another one that i never really got into
the method ghost and ray album
it was disappointing for that trio you
know like there was some jokes on there
but
um pretty tony was close for me
ghostface yeah if you go through
ghostface whole entire uh
apollo kids ghost deeney was cool more
fish i never [ __ ] with i thought that
[ __ ] was wack
that was just like that was so he could
get off def jam big though rehab was all
right
um yeah man unfortunately jizza had a
outside of grand masters i like legends
of the liquid sword
um yeah
yeah shout out to uh shout out to wu
tang though i feel like they're not
celebrated enough
well i mean i don't know if i agree with
you there buddy because they do have a
[ __ ]
they just had a goddamn showtime
documentary series and then hulu made an
entire [ __ ] tv show based on their
lives
so i'm not sure i can agree with you
buddy i still i feel like nowadays they
don't get
the love they deserve well because kids
don't give a [ __ ] about wu-tang clan
it's unfortunate but it is what it is
wu-tang is for the children wu-tang is
for is are they
i mean recipes they're mcgirt
best skits ever on 36 chambers too i
forgot to mention
oh yeah torture scales in front of
method man
that's what's crazy is it that [ __ ]
skit was
in front of the most commercially
successful song on the album
so if you bought that album for the meth
ody man well i guess cream but
but if you bought that and you had to
put that [ __ ] on you were like what the
[ __ ] are these [ __ ] talking
about putting hangers in each other's
asses and
nailing dicks on the [ __ ] yeah what the
[ __ ]
shit's crazy